هلا وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبد
الله هيان النطيران تسلمت رسائل من اطراف
في الاتفاق النووي عبر قطر مشيرا الى ان
الدوحه تحاول اعاده جميع الاطراف في
الاتفاق النووي الى التزاماتها عبد الله
هيام اشار في مؤتمر صحفي مشتركين مع
النائب رئيس مجلس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه
القطريه الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني
الى دور الدوحه الفعالي في المحادثات بين
بلاده واوكرانيا
استلمنا رسائل من اطراف في اتفاق النووي
بواسطه دوله قطر ونشكرها على دورها
الايجابي من اجل اعاده الاطراف الاتفاق
النووي والتواصل الاتفاق المثمر اليوم
الساعه ان تبذلها قطر للتواصل الاتفاق واي
وجهه نظر تقدمها نرحب بها هناك اقتراحات
قدمها الشيخ محمد بخصوص المحادثات
العسكريه والسياسيه بين ايران واوكرانيا
التي اقيمت في عمان لقد بذلت قطر جهودا
مشكوره وتقوم بدون فعال في المحادثات بشان
اوكرانيا
انا واموره خالص من جانبه قال نايبو رئيس
مجلس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري الشيخ
محمد بن عبد الرحمن ال ثاني الولايات
المتحده حملت الدوحه بعض الرسائل الى
طهران في موضوع يخص الاتفاق النووي
والقضايا المختلفه المحيطه به واشار الى
ان الفرصه الان مواطيه لحل المشاكل
المحيطه بهذا الاتفاق وان الدوحه تتسعى
لتوفير بيئه مولائمه لعقد جولات مفاوضات
اضافيه بشان الارتفاع كما شدد اعلى اهميه
تعزيز الامن الاقليمي وضروره خفض التصعيد
في المنطقه
كان لدينا فرصه للحديث عن اهميه تعزيز
الامن الاقليمي وخفض التصعيد في المنطقه و
دوله قطر ودول مجلس التعاون ايضا تشجع على
الدخول في حوار وفق مبادئ قانون الدولي
وعدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه للدول
واحترام حسن الجوار وهذه العلاقات التي
نريد ان نبنيها مع جميع جيراننا